THE FLORIDA SCHOOL SHOOTING,
THIS SHERIFF'S REACTION AND THE
STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL
KIDS, THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
WE BROUGHT TO YOU LAST NIGHT
EXCLUSIVE NEWS ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING BEHIND THE SCENES, NEW
AND SHOCKING DETAILS ABOUT THE
ACTIVITY OF THE BROWARD COUNTY
POLICE UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
SHERIFF SCOTT ISRAEL.
WE SHARED WITH YOU A DEPARTMENT
EMAIL ASKING OFFICERS TO DEFEND
THE SHERIFF.
IT READ "AT THE MOMENT WE FIND
OUR AGENCY UP AGAINST A FLURRY
OF MEDIA ALLEGATIONS AND A
PERSONAL ATTACK AGAINST OUR
SHERIFF, SHERIFF ISRAEL STOOD
WITH US.
NOW WE MUST STAND WITH HIM.
IT'S IMPORTANT THEY KNOW WE
STAND AS ONE."
THIS SHOULDN'T BE NOT ABOUT
SAVING ANYONE'S BACKSIDE BUT
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY.
NOT PROTECTING THE SHERIFF OR
ANYONE ELSE.
SHERIFF ISRAEL HAS ENDORSED GUN
CONTROL AND FOR THAT HE WON
PRAISE FROM STUDENT ACTIVISTS
AND THIS IS HAPPENING AS HIS
DEPARTMENT'S ACTIONS BEFORE,
DURING, AND AFTER THE HORRIFIC
SCHOOL SHOOTING ARE NOW BEING
INVESTIGATED BY A SEPARATE STATE
COMMISSION.
WHEN CHALLENGED, ISRAEL -- DON'T
FORGET, UNELECTED DEMOCRATIC
SHERIFF -- BRAGGED ABOUT HIS
AMAZING LEADERSHIP.
BUT IT MAY NOT HAVE BEEN SO
AMAZING.
LAST NIGHT WE REPORT EXCLUSIVELY
THAT SOURCES CLOSE TO THE
BROWARD SHERIFF'S OFFICE ARE
TELLING US THAT DEPUTIES ON THE
SCENE OF THE SHOOTING WERE TOLD
NOT TO ENTER THE SCHOOL UNLESS
THEIR BODY CAMERAS WERE TURNED
ON.
SINCE THEY DID NOT HAVE BODY
CAMERAS, THEY DIDN'T ENGAGE THE
SHOOTER OR ENTER THE SCHOOL.
THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE BY THE WAY
HAS NOT DISPUTED OUR REPORT.
WHEN ASKED ABOUT THE DEPUTIES
WHO FAILED TO ENTER THE SCHOOL
BUILDING, BROWARD SUPERINTENDENT
SAID THERE POTENTIALLY COULD
HAVE BEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
WERE SITTING ON THE SIDELINES.
WE'LL SEE WHAT COMES OUT OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
THE BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE AND THE FBI HAS ALL THE
VIDEO RELATED TO THIS.
WE HAVE NONE OF IT IN OUR
POSSESSION.
THEY MADE THAT CLEAR.
THEY CAME, THEY GAVE US A
WARRANT AND A SUBPOENA AND THEY
TOOK IT ALL.
REMEMBER, SHERIFF ISRAEL SAID
THAT THE VIDEOS MAY NEVER BE
RELEASED, ANOTHER BIZARRE
COMMENT.
HOW DO YOU SAY THAT?
IT'S NOT CLEAR IF THE FEDS HAVE
THE VIDEO AS WELL, IT WOULD EVEN
BE HIS FULL DECISION AT THIS
POINT.
THEN THERE ARE THE PARKLAND
FLORIDA SCHOOL STUDENTS, THEY
SPENT THROUGH A LOT.
FOR ANYONE WHO HAS BEEN
CONSCIOUS, THE MEDIA HAS
FEATURED THESE KIDS WALL TO
WALL, THEIR PASSION, THEIR WORDS
WALL, THEIR PASSION, THEIR WORD
WORDS.
I WOULD ARGUE THEIR PAIN AND
LOSS IS AT TIMES OF BEING
EXPLOITED BY ANTI-GUN ACTIVISTS,
SOMETIMES USING THEM AS PROXIES.
REMEMBER THIS FROM THE CNN TOWN
HALL.
>> SENATOR RUBIO, IT'S HARD TO
LOOK AT YOU AND NOT LOOK DOWN
THE BARREL OF AN AR-15, CAN YOU
TELL ME RIGHT NOW THAT YOU WILL
NOT EXCEPT A SINGLE DONATION
FROM THE NRA?
>> Laura: NICE.
SOME OF THE EXCHANGES, I IMAGINE
THE SHERIFF WOULDN'T LIKE IT IF
HIS OFFICERS WERE SPOKEN TO IN
THAT TONE.
HE THEN REVEALED HIMSELF.
>> WE DO NEED TO HAVE SOME
GUN-CONTROL REFORM.
18-YEAR-OLDS SHOULD NEVER HAVE A
RIFLE AND 18-YEAR-OLD SHOULD NOT
HAVE A RIFLE.
18-YEAR-OLD KID -- THEY ARE NOT
ADULTS YET.
THEY ARE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
THESE KIDS SHOULD NOT HAVE A
RIFLE.
>> Laura: YOU HEAR WHAT HE
SAID?
KIDS.
THEY ARE STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL.
THEY ARE GOING THROUGH A LOT.
IT'S SOMETHING CALLED GROWING UP
IT'S SOMETHING CALLED GROWING U
UP.
SHERIFF ISRAEL MADE UNWITTINGLY
ONE OF THE SALIENT POINTS HERE.
WHY ON EARTH SHOULD TEENAGERS
DICTATE POLICY ON GUN CONTROL?
OR ANYTHING ELSE FOR THAT
MATTER?
WITHOUT DIMINISHING THEIR PAIN
OR SADNESS OR THE RIGHT TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPINION ABOUT THE
SLAUGHTER OF THEIR FELLOW
CLASSMATES, WHY SHOULD THEIR
POLITICAL POLICY VIEWS -- WHERE
TALKING 14, 15, 16-YEAR-OLD KIDS
BE GIVEN SPECIAL CONSIDERATION?
WHEN THEY'RE NOT INSULTING
CONGRESSMAN OR SENATORS, THEY
ARE ADVISING THEM ON GUN POLICY.
>> YOU JUST MET WITH ABOUT FIVE
STUDENTS, I'VE HEARD A LOT OF
CONSERVATIVES SAY THESE KIDS
AREN'T EXPERTS, WHY ARE THEY
HAVE A GOOD INFLUENCE ON THIS
DEBATE?
YOU MET WITH THEM SO WHAT DID
YOU THINK?
>> IT'S HIGH SCHOOL KIDS, A
SYMPATHETIC GROUP, VERY
ARTICULATE, COMMITTED BUNCH OF
KIDS.
THEY ARE OBVIOUSLY SOCIAL MEDIA
SAVVY AND THAT'S WHY I THINK
THEY ARE HAVING THE IMPACT THAT
THEY ARE HAVING.
THEY ARE ORGANIZED AND THEY ARE
HERE.
I'M GLAD THEY ARE AND I HOPE
THEY KEEP IT UP.
>> THESE GUNS ARE OUT THERE ON
THE STREET THAT PEOPLE WHO MAY
BE UNSTABLE ARE ABLE TO GET IT
JUST AS ANYBODY ELSE.
>> IF WE EVER WANT TO END THIS
WE HAVE TO START AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE THE
LAW IS SUPREME, THAT'S WHERE WE
HAVE TO TAKE ACTION.
>> Laura: SPEAKING OF SENATOR
SENATOR FLAKE WHO IS RETIRING
BECAUSE 18% APPROVAL, I WOULD
PREFERRED THE STUDENTS TO MOST
OF HIS ADVISORS OVER THE YEARS.
THAT OF HAVING BEEN SAID, BEFORE
THREE OF THE STUDENTS WENT ON
ELLEN DeGENERES IS POPULAR
TALK SHOW, AGF THEM BACKSTAGE
APPEARED ON TWITTER.
THEY LOOKED LIKE OSCAR NOMINEES,
THEY LOOK ADORABLE.
PERHAPS
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"'S,
BILL McGURN RAISED THE BEST
QUESTION ABOUT THE KIDS TURNED
POLICY EXPERTS.
QUICK SHOW OF HANDS FOR THOSE
WITH CHILDREN.
HOW MANY OF YOU LOOK TO YOUR
TEENS FOR POLITICAL WISDOM
WHETHER IT'S YOUR DAUGHTER
OBSESSING OVER SNAPSHOT OR THE
SON SPENDING HIS DAY BINGE
EATING DORITOS.